hi I'm Eli Roth with Fandango movie
clips here are some things to know
before you go for my new film the green
inferno the green inferno is about a
bunch of students from New York City
that decide they are gonna go and save
the Amazon and they're gonna stop
construction to protect the last
uncontacted tribe they save the tribe
and on the way home their plane crashes
and the villagers think they're
intruders and dark them and take them in
the village and they kids become their
food supply the green inferno was filmed
in a village that is completely cut off
from society we had to conceptually
explain to this village what a movie was
how did we do that
the Peruvian producers gathered the
whole village around and they said we're
gonna show you a movie called Cannibal
Holocaust this is the single most
violent film ever made
luckily the villagers thought it was a
comedy and all 300 villagers voted and
they agreed to let us shoot there now
these people had never acted before so
we had to explain to them action cut the
kids loved it they loved picking up the
parts of the dead bodies everybody
wanted to be covered in blood
everybody wanted to eat somebody they
all thought it was hilarious they
thought we were making a comedy and they
were amazing actors imagine someone with
no awareness of the camera no frame of
reference for what it's like to be
photographed so they were amazing they
were some of the best actors I ever
worked with
the kids in the movie really really got
into it they caught a baby Python the
kids thought it would be funny if when
the Americans are the cagey through a
live snake at them and I was like that's
actually a great idea we were shooting
in Chile where the safety laws are a
little bit different so the actors Kirby
and Magda let's me the go wait is that
thing poisonous we don't know no no it's
a Python
don't worry I'm hiding but if you're
gonna go action excellent and the kids
are just like dangling slapping these
girls in the face with a Python and if
you freeze frame it the snake is like
its teeth are out literally an inch from
their eyeballs the green inferno is
inspired by Occupy Wall Street it's
about kids that latch on to causes that
maybe they don't know everything about
or don't believe in or latch on to it
cause it's trendy I kept noticing
hashtag of the week is everyone going
how can you not care
Kony 2012 child soldiers in Uganda you
get the feeling that now there are these
kind of social justice warriors that are
out there to make you feel bad about
everything social activism can be great
it can be in this amazing
for change but so many people I feel
doing it not because they believe in the
cause but because they want to look like
they care they love being on the home
page of Reddit I want to see kids like
that just get eaten by balls torn up get
their tongue sliced off genitals
mutilated I want full-on cannibal gore
that for me is hilarious so green
inferno is a terrifying movie but in a
very perverse way it's really fun to
watch these kids get it I'm Eli Roth for
Fandango movie clips thanks for watching
and check out the green inferno
September 25th can you take the heat